yeah okay so you're not Eliot Chang you
know Eliot yeah he's nice yeah he's nice
yeah he's got a nice body brother he's
funny slim do you think Elliot's funny I
guess he's cool I don't really I know he
is yeah Eliot's funny yeah you say yeah
he's funny yeah Wow there's a war he's
cool a problem all right all right
his brandy you're not into that you look
like you might it's like watching a
basketball player
he scores baskets I don't like how he
plays I don't play politically good you
know but how do you know Yoshi mm-hmm
good friends with you Yoshi no just
nobody is yeah yeah you like him watch
me he wants me and my family dead
mix-ins don't oh there's a part of
Japanese yeah that's right yeah so he
threatened uh he threatened my family's
life in my life here on my podcast tell
him that he's like why I you know shout
out just a shout-out to Yoshi okay he
looks like he just seems like a nice guy
but he is very thick he will hurt you
yeah yeah yeah he does look like you can
he looks like you could hurt you
yeah I'm so sorry Yoshi if you're
listening no I'm being really I won't do
my apology I I you know I I think it's
enough time has passed genuine and I
want to be genuine and I want to talk
about I want to apologize to a lot of
people right now but my number one
apology is to Yoshi I think you're a
funny dude I when I said it about you on
David chose podcast which is in a joking
matter just so that I could just side
with David about something but I respect
you thank you for all the free porn you
gave me over the years I want to be
friends again
but if you don't I understand but that's
that will still have to apologize to I
think that's it you've been pretty good
lately you've stayed out of the metal
Wars yeah I mean above the frame when I
apologized to Vince Vaughn oh don't
apologize so he's doing just fine I
apologize for that know who else did it
work that's it
I think that's pretty much it ari and i
cool and Lenore and I are cool you don't
start wars huh
try not to there's no one in the on the
face that comment doesn't hate you I
don't you know what a few like I don't
know that's a good thing though I think
that I think that for I'll be on earth
for you to make it in the business you
have to have a stable of guys that hate
you know people have gone out the way to
try to get get under my skin I just
gotta ignore oh really
I've done a chair of somebody okay
that's a good sign your careers fine
yeah because like Rosanna like for
instance like you know I've said this
before I'm gonna say it again what Mitzi
sure once said to me it's like the only
way to make it in this business is if
you're somebody they can have half the
audience love you and hate you at the
same time 50% hate you 50% love you if
you have a hundred but that's hard to do
that's Tom Hanks it is so hard so but if
you can get people to hate you as you
know we are there people that hate Tom
Hanks do you think I don't hate I don't
know Thomas is the only one like Tom
Hanks people love universally yeah I
think people like Will Smith universally
the rock they're wrong yeah the rock
universally I think Ellen DeGeneres is
somebody no you know it's some of the
people hate her
oh really because of what she represents
one person I think Anne Hathaway seems
like she seems like yeah her people say
they love ya and Heather is a great
example polarizing very polarizing yeah
but that's what you need that's what
Missy says like you know a lot of people
hate Jim Carrey but they love them right
yeah yeah it's very hard to be a Tom the
world many ways Jim Carrey no I know
people that are like people that are
educated oh yeah that people that were
educated and Ivy League they're like
he's too broad for this he's over to top
my tips are people like her like Jewish
friends they just can't stay in him
they're like he's the worst comedian
I've ever seen banana black dudes love
them like so it's like I don't know
subject my caps it's just I love him
don't you love my caps
yeah I do you know I don't know oh my
god I've had a couple of encounters with
him he's always been nice
but um he's just high love them what are
your stories with him well I don't I had
something I just heard some other
stories but I don't know I can say I
can't say he's having the up - I'm up to
no good
I'm trying to edit myself because you
know we've been editing in his podcast
trying to edit yourself you're just
trying to not say some [ __ ] every
two seconds a Gilbert has to add then
edit but of so far it's you you don't
have any so far we've been good right
that's great yeah so far this is ad free
right what do I you know [ __ ] [ __ ] these
guys generic [ __ ] you just [ __ ] all
these guys that are doing all this stuff
up there raping and stuff